ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد الوضع السياسي
في افغانستان وداخل اروقه السلطه لدى حركه
طالبان التي تحكم السيطره على البلاد منذ
عام ونصف هذا الوضع يشهد توترا وانشقاقا
يزداد يوما بعد يوم فقد بدات درجه حقاني
وزير الداخليه في حكومه طالبان في قياده
تحرك داخلي مع بعض القاده البارزين داخل
الحركه لاقامه مجلس شورى للحكم يتخذ
قراراته بعيدا عن احتكار زعيم الحركه هبه
الله اخ زاده للسلطه بحسب ما اكدت مصادر
للعربيه المصادر ذكرت ان غالبيه القاده
ممتعظون من عدم تجاوب زعيم طالبا معهم
ورفضه اللقاء بهم كما اشارت الى انه ورغم
محاولاتهم لثنياه عن بعض القرارات يرفض اخ
زاده العضوله او التراجع عنها الى ذلك
كشفت المصادر ان حقاني استطاع استعماله
وزير الدفاع محمد يعقوب
ابرز قاده حركه طالبان الملهبه الله اخ
زاده يتولى زعامه الحركه منذ عام 2016
المرجع الاعلى للامور السياسيه والدينيه
والعسكريه
الملا عبد الحكيم كبير القضاه ويشرف على
نظام طالبان القضائي الملا عبد الغني
برادر احد مؤسسي حركه طالبان مع الملا عمر
يعتبر القائد العسكري لطالبان
سراج الدين حقاني الرجل الثاني في طالبان
وزعيم الشبكه التي تحمل اسم عائلته
الملا يعقوب نجل الملا محمد عمر هو رئيس
اللجنه العسكريه التي تتمتع بنفوذ كبير في
طالبان
[موسيقى]
في البدايه اهلا بك وضيفك الكريم نعم ما
حدث ان سراج حقاني يريد
باي طريقه ما تغيير شكل الحكم في داخل
طالبان او بمعنى اصح يريد منع احتكار
السلطه
والذي اصدر قرارات يعني
جعلت القاده امثال الحقاني وغيره من الذين
لديهم علاقات دوليه
مع عدد من الدول وجعلتهم في موقف حرج
بانهم بان هذيك بان تلك الدول ابلغتهم بان
الاعتراف الدولي بما الاعتراف الرسمي
بحكومه الطالبان سيكون من المستحيل في ظل
هذه القرارات التي تصدر
باعتقادي اذا كان هذا صحيح او لا نعم صحيح
بحكم ان حقاني بدا يذهب الى المناطق التي
بها لافهم انك هذا الانقلاب الناعم كما
اكدت بانه قادر ان يكون موجود ويعمل عليه
في هذه المرحله هو لدوافع الاقتراب اكثر
من من المجتمع الدولي اكثر منه دوافع
تشهدها الحركه داخليا
هو يحتمل الوجهين لو عدنا بالاصح ان حقاني
وحقاني وحتى غيري من القاده كان بين تنافس
شديد داخل الحركه
منذ وفاه الملا عمر ومنذ اعلان وفاه الملا
عمر مؤسسه الحركه في 2015
هذه هذا التنافس كان بينهم على المناصف
الداخليه والخارجيه ولكن بعد سيطره طالبان
ازدادت هذا التنافس حتى اصبح الان هناك
التقارب اصبح هناك امر اخر وهو من يتقرب
اكثر من المجتمع الدولي من يستطيع الحصول
على
فوائد اكثر من المجتمع الدولي حقاني بدا
في هذه الحمله واشبه ما تقوم بحمله علاقات
عامه بالنسبه له كان يعمل بها سابقا بشكل
هادئ ولا نصبح يذهب الى المناطق التي
يتمتع فيها بنفوذ قويه منذ عشرون عاما هو
واسرته خصوصا في ولايات شرق افغانستان كان
قبل ايام في ولايه خوست واليوم كان في
ولايه لوجر كذلك شرق افغانستان
اليوم لم يتحدث كما تحدث الاسبوع الماضي
من انتقاده بشكل غير مباشر
لزعيم طالبان في احتكاره للسلطه وتشويه
سمعه النظام وانه يجب عليهم ان يتقربوا من
الشعب لا ان ينفروهم ويجعلوهم يكرهون
الدين
حقاني بدا يعمل بشكل قوي في مناطق نفوذي
بدايه مناطق نفوذه وحتى انه يحاول التقارب
مع بعض القاده داخل الحركه في محاوله ان
يجد
دعم داخلي لتحركه ومحاوله اقناع زعيم
طالبان بالعدول عن قراراته وتشكيل المجلس
شورى للحكم لا يختص ذلك المجلس
بعرض القضايا واصدار القرارات بحيث لا
يحتكر زعيم طالبان السلطه بيده وحتى ان
اصدر
حكما يعود الى المجلس الحكم طالبين
دكتور فضل الله ما رايك يقول ضيف ي بان
حقاني كان العسكر ربما وحاول ان يعمل ان
يرتب الامور بما يمكنه من التقرب للمجتمع
الدولي ومن تحقيق دعم كذلك في داخل
الافغاني هل تعتقد بان حقاني قادر وما
المنتظر من موقف اخون زاد كذلك
تحيه طيبه وبعد لديه الكريم
في الحقيقه رجعنا اصلا
فكري
لحقاني وكذلك ملا حيبه الله اخ انتم
تعرفون تماما
هو ابن الاكبر او ارشد لجلادين حقاني
القائد الراحل
الجهادي السابق لافغانستان فبالتالي له
امتداد الفكري الحركي المتنور انجاز تعبير
فهو يقود هذه الفكره في صفوف طالبان كذلك
لديهم امتداد وعلاقات القديمه ما قاده
الحركه ما قاده الجهات السابقين
لافغانستان
الاتحاد السوفيتي فبالتالي كذلك ملاحظه
يعني ه
[موسيقى]
على فكره او ممكن امتداد لفكره تقليديه
ملا يعني حركه الملا جاد التعبير فهناك
تميز او
هناك فروقات داخل من اصل وفي نفس الوقت
او هذه الاختلافات كانت تحكى وكانت تنشر
كقراءات ولكن لم تكن هناك تصريحات يعني في
بعض التصريحات التي نقلها نقلتها بعض
قيادات طالبان يقول البعض بان هناك شبه
تهديد بان حقاني قال لاخون زاده هذه
البدايه فقط والقادم قد يكون اسوا لك
السؤال حقاني قادر ان ينفصل على زعيم
طالبان تماما
هناك اشكاليه اشكاليه ان الان
الجميل قرارات التي تتخذ ثمن من قندهار
ليس من عاصمه الكابل فبالتالي هناك لقاءات
التشاور صعب جدا وصول الى كندهار هناك
وكذلك هناك
اذا تمرات حقاني وكذلك ولا يعقوب حاولوا
لقاء بزعيم القاده تشاورما مثل قد يتلم
البنات مثل هذا ولكن هم لم ينجحوا بذلك
هذا تباين تباين الاخر في نفس الوقت ان
هناك نوم اشكاليه بين متعهدات التي حصلت
اشكاليه حول التنفيذ قرارات او تعهدات
التي تعهدت حركه التاليفان في الدوحه مال
الامريكان وما مجتمع الدولي هؤلاء قاده
السياسيين وكذلك قاده الاسكرين خاف الذين
يمثلون
القندهارين هذا الذي قال انه هناك اشكاليه
تباين نظر حول هذا التعاقدات دوليه
وبالتالي هذه هي اشكاليه حقيقيه داخل حركه
الطالبان ولكن حتى طالبان في هذا الامر هي
تقول بانه لم يتم نقض هذه التعهدات هذه
التعهدات كانت ستكون موجوده ان تم ادراجنا
او على الاقل ادماجنا في هذه الحكومه
بطريقه سياسيه ولكن نحن تحصلنا على الحكم
بكل ما تابعناه من تفاصيل ولكن ساعود
لكلمه كنت طرقت لها حضرتك تحدثت عن ان كلا
الطرفين يملك دعما حقيقيا بداخل الافغاني
وهنا استاذ سيد هل يمكن ان نشهد مواجهه
بين معسكرين لطلبان
كما ذكرت بان هناك جميع يحظون بدعم يعني
داخلي في الاصل بانه زعيم طالبان يحظى
بالدعم من القيادات في جنوب افغانستان في
مسقط راسي في قنداره حتى ولايه المانجا
ورزكان ولكن هذا الدعم الداخلي يجعله
ضعيفا نوعا ما هو ان بعض القيادات حتى من
قندهار امثال لا يعقوب وزير الدفاع النجم
المؤسس الحركه الملا عمر وحتى صهر الملا
عمر الملا عبد الغني بدر هم من جنوب
افغانستان احد من قندهار والاخر من رزقان
هؤلاء كذلك يحضرون بدعم داخلي في طالبان
ومن جهه اخرى حتى ان حقان يحظى بدعم كبير
في ولايته شرق افغانستان بالتالي سوف يكون
هناك يعني داخليا يكون هناك فرق منقسمه
لكن هذه الفرق المنقسمه جميع تتحد نوعا ما
بخلاف الملا ابو رادر حتى الان لم يتفق
معه حقا في هذه المساله بسبب الخلافات
السابقه بينهما ولكن هذه
الفرق الداخليه في طالبان تتحد جميع ضد
زعيم طالبان في ان يحاولوا تغيير سلوكه في
الحكم كما تحدث ضيفك الكريم بان المناهبه
الله هو الرجل ديني تقليدي جدا
وسراج الدين حقاني رجل يتمتع بعلاقات
دوليه كبيره وخصوصا مع بعض الدول المجاوره
على استبعاده اتحدث شكلا ومضمونا شكلا
كحضور ومضمون كمقرر
يعني
مؤسس كمسؤول عن بعض القرارات قادر على ذلك
حقاني
هناك تكون خطوتين اذا قام بها حقاني من
المتوقع بان يستطيع ان
يبعد هبه الله عن الحكومه او حتى انه يحجم
من نفوذه وسلطاته الطريقه الاول هو انه
يحظى بدعم داخلي ويحظى حتى بالدعم من
القيادات داخل طالبان بحيث تشكل قوه اكبر
من قوه قندهار وهذا نوعا ما صعب حتى الان
في الوقت الحاضر ولكن العمليه لدى لدى
حقاني تجري على قدم وثاق ومن جهه اخرى
نفود او علاقات حقاني بعدد من الدول
وخصوصا باكستان لديه علاقات ومن جهه اخرى
حتى
باكستان لديها القدره والسلطه نوعا ما من
تشكيل الضغط على زعيم طالبان بالتالي
اعتقد لو انك باكستان اصطفت الى جانب
حقاني ضد زعيمي طالبان من المتوقع بان
يحضر حقاني بدعم اكبر في افغانستان ولكن
باعتقادي بان افغانستان هي بشكل عام مجتمع
تقليدي
[موسيقى]
داخل افغانستا هناك تمن في تقليديه
داخل الطالبان
كما يقولون قنده هارينهم والذين يصرون على
مواقيف وفي نفس الوقت يقولون
اسرار النجاحهم او سيطرتهم على البلد
اوداعمهم
تغذيه ثقافيه التي اتوهلب قاتليهم حتى
يشجعهم للقتال هذه شعارات كندا من ضمنها
من تعليم من هذا الامر الان هم كانوا
يخشون ولكن
يمكن ان يقترحه وحقاني قد يؤثر او قد يهز
من الصوره من الرمزيه التي
اسست لها القيادات في السابق سنكتفي بهذا
القدر على ان تبقى العين على كل التطورات
الخاصه بهذا الموضوع اود شكرا جزيلا شكرا
من الرياضه الصحفي الافغاني احمد سيد ومن
كابولا دكتور فضل الله ممتاز المحلله
السياسي شكرا لكما
[موسيقى]